yellow welcome to a new game I saw the
15 minute game again and he 4 was played
I go for some modern defense stuff for a
change didn't play this kind of line
that are often here in the videos so
let's see what setup the opponent down
will come up with he's already played
Knight f3 pretty early so the most
aggressive aggressive options are ruled
out already with f4 f3 or something okay
it's gone for quick am Bishop to c4 so
quite solid line I'm not entirely sure
what what's correct here of course I can
just play Knight f6 but maybe I have
some other ideas to make use of the
Knights not yet being played to f6 let's
say c6
for instance or move like that or maybe
c5 even let's play the play c6
maybe I can even fly d65 at some point
winning a tempo on the bishop of course
I've used D 6 and D 5 which is also to
move so it's not really an extra tempo
or something but okay we retreated to b3
voluntarily I think this makes some
sense if I would play and move like b5
now which okay that doesn't make much
sense here anyway because that so no
knight on c3 and if there's no knight on
c3 b5 issues usually pointless but I'd
be five he could immediately play a four
so certainly a useful move I think I
don't I don't have much choice when to
play Knight f6 okay it's not a bad move
so no problem there usually white places
Queen to e2 in this line with the bishop
on c4 or b3 in this case often the Queen
only two would support throw the push of
the e pawn Knight c3 is serve is unusual
and this some kind of setup usually you
want to play the pawn to c3 to support
and support the center okay let's just
castle
yeah one keep-keep point and this kind
of setups for black as always what to do
with the light squared bishop because
it's usually pretty useless peace cannot
yeah take up and effective post anywhere
a long time you could go be five and be
should be seven and so on but it's a
very very time-consuming that is an idea
however just to play Bishop g4 and
exchange this off but well yeah
certainly not not such a bad idea i
guess it's a pretty useless piece anyway
okay interesting question now
and so what to do with the the center
the central setup I could do various
things I could try just a five which is
certainly solid way to do it but yeah I
think what should be somewhat better
than with the bishop panel but it's no
big deal
certainly okay for black it's fairly
solid also another idea would be maybe
to to go for c5 you know other setups
don't really make sense like b5 and
stuff like this maybe just play Knight
bd7 first here and then try to decide if
you play if I play Safari four or five
okay let's go for you far from need to
stake some claim in the center
simple solution for white would be now
just to to take on e5 only played d5 or
didn't expect that at all don't think
this is a very dangerous move for me
okay let's go quickly through them the
possible ways to play well CD 5 is I
think easily dismissed because white
just has got nice control on d5 I don't
have anything concrete for that
especially this Bishop on g7 that it
looks stupid so I cannot really take on
d5 I could let him take on c6 so just
keep the tension with queenie 7 or
knight b6 or some move that doesn't
involve pawn move this was playable but
I think the simplest way to do it is
just a closer position to c5 this is a
simple solution and it's a pretty much
deadens the bishop on b3 this piece now
is completely dead it can be
repositioned of course and this is also
what I would try here if I was in white
shoes like maneuvers like somehow move
the knight and c4 c3 and then get this
bishop back into the game or just Bishop
c4 yeah of course just Bishop c4 is the
simplest way Bishop c4 and then maybe a
4 okay yeah well I guess he he also saw
that he needs to do something about this
piece but he did it in another way yeah
but this is a very clumsy piece
configuration here maybe I should just
try to play a fire f5 quickly to get
something going against this pieces so I
got play play Knight to e8 try to play a
5 quickly as long as this bishop is bad
on b3 I think I should try to make use
of this a 5 would be much more difficult
to play if he would have already had the
bishop and c2 and I don't know
Knight to g3 or something so okay let's
let's play a5 now right yeah
yeah the whole piece his whole pizza
tabatha is somewhat clumsy with the
Queen on f3 night only two and Bishop on
b3 so these pieces don't really work
together very well yeah maybe he should
just play Knight c3 back here to get
also some squares for the Queen to
retreat
what I'm not so sure about if he am play
some I don't know let's say let's say
Bishop c2 and I'm not sure what what I
would do then would I just would have
player four in this position I'm not
sure it could be an idea because of this
strange piece of setup
maybe I can quickly after a four play G
5 H 5 g 4 and so on and made to come
maybe but I don't have this light square
the light squared bishop anymore
exchange this off early and once you
don't have the light squared bishop this
kind of Kings Indian structures with F
form need to be assessed really yeah
really correctly otherwise it's it's
it's not so great yeah okay he played
notes it was one of the moves I expected
I have another idea actually maybe I can
I can I can also consider Knight Queen
to h4 here with the idea with Bishop f6
to exchange off my bed Bishop could be
an idea okay let's let's go for this
it's also maybe one one idea you you
need to keep in mind this may be here F
for let's say he moves the Queen in case
he moves the queen of cocaine out to g3
but let's say I move the Queen to d1 or
e2 or something then I would play f1 and
f3 to break up the the King position and
then the Queen would be very nice on h4
yes this was a move home I had some
doubts about if this would be fine for
me or not so I didn't really expect him
to play it so okay hmm yeah the question
is they exchanged on d3 g3 I'm not sure
if I like this this kind of
transformation of course he's got them
this double pawn I could play I could
take on d4 and then I would have five
worthless form the Queen side but I'm
not sure I think it's it's his pieces
what would improve considerably if I
retreat the Queen to e7 he might play on
he might play a fall
but on f4 maybe I have an interesting
move thought that maybe I maybe I had to
g5 but yeah maybe the Queen g3 added
underestimate a bit
okay let's retreat to e7 this course
threat is the simple user form I think
what needs to play a for himself now
looks looks logical at least unless some
there's some specific drawback when F F
for I had the good idea a g5 which would
be nice if he would take with the pawn
anywhere on g5 45 then I would have F
for 2 to 4 come night and queen and and
Bishop for g5 F takes G 5 f 1 or F takes
d5 f 1 and that will win a piece but he
can take with the Queen on g5 and then
it doesn't make so much sense could take
the Queen a player 4 but this is some
this is not not great for me so let's
consider him playing f4 now I could on
their form
yeah I could take on that farm or take
on e4
yeah this was the other basic
possibility of course and then and now a
form
yeah you want to do I want to play you
form well not really but I cannot also
cannot really let him take here maybe I
could not not the end of the world I
would have 96 and then also if we
capture with the porn maybe I have can
play one moves before I commit this
despair in the center
yeah okay come on let's let's close this
yeah this is some kind of a standard
position Kings Indian type of position
where White's main plan is to play d4
pawn to g4 at some point okay this is I
don't know strange booth well normal I
guess would have been a maybe it was
afraid of Bishop takes c3 but yeah
okay this could be could be an idea okay
let's consider options here I could I'm
asking myself what is does it make any
sense to play Bishop the foreign
exchange this bishop okay come on I need
to look on the G file anyway so
oh no it gets it gets bit bizarre
okay maybe maybe I try maybe allows me
to play even Bishop h4 to g3 or
something
uh-huh
yeah I guess he has to play Bishop after
no or this one one one of those two
moose cannot really allow really except
me playing and neither Bishop to d3 okay
yeah I tried to get more pieces towards
the kingside
yeah it's not so easy to UM to make to
make progress here
yeah his fearly tries to play g4 I guess
yeah maybe can play it next move
h5 is not really helpful I would like to
play this but the king is of course he
can they can just play g4 on h5
here maybe it was just bad to play in
the night 297
okay let's drop this back
no idea what this was doing okay okay it
had an idea okay now he cannot play g4
because I got yes zone rook on h7 No so
this should stop yeah this really
stopped is g4 ambitions but this is of
course also weird okay let's get rid of
this Bishop and then quickly put the
knight on d4
yeah I cannot really take on default
zone
this would give me just too much
yeah um I try to try to invade only six
years
yeah yeah b5 tries to make use of the
fact that d5 is not very well protected
so he takes on b5 a B night XP 5 I have
five t5 to capture its pieces are
somewhat clumsy here especially the
Queen
yeah I'm down to two minutes so need to
be conscious yet not to fall to you too
too much behind in time yeah okay we
have now an open file first time in the
game so try to of course get get over
them pretty quick here with some
transferring piece yeah next move could
be yeah we to e8 this is also neatly
covering h5 and also a forum for ideas
like night lied to a for his pressure on
h5 so I can play rook d7 Nick Smith and
I can also consider a nitrogen form I
guess he can he cannot let it stay that
he needs to take it and then c4 would
also be a weakness okay let's go he
takes g4 now I might even take on c4
Knight takes e4 Queen Queen e2 I guess
Knight xe3
bishop take takes h5 whom not sure about
this need to move the Queen yeah it
should be should be good for me
yeah it should be you should be good
let's go for this
I should have taken him I thought it
would be fine for me but this would have
been of course much more critical than
this now this is just an extra exchange
and he doesn't have much to show for it
I guess nothing
yeah I just need to get okay
need to get the Queen into play hmm okay
you can take now come in Syria okay but
but I'm pinning the night so he kept it
just has the single check I cannot
really in vatm
I was a bit afraid of Queen f6 first but
of course the night is just hanging and
this is just winning
yeah needs to exchange Queens now and
then it's just a complete win with the
pawn going through
time warning no okay but don't manage I
think
checkmate yeah what's a pretty Priyanka
game for for quite some time despite the
fact that you made quite a lot of
strange-looking boosts I guess this is
some indication that I didn't play
perfectly as well
yeah maybe at this point here I'm I
should just play a four maybe but this
kind of transformation isn't so great
for me it's it's not terrible but if he
would have I don't know use his image is
better here
let's same here in this position I don't
know why doesn't he just played you for
I think why this sum is just better
after g4 so it's it's not fatal or
winning or something but white is better
and or here even it's still possible
now it's not easy not easy at all
I think and after h4 it completely turns
around and now I think black is even
preferable
not sure I was down to two minutes so
cannot really be too critical about them
above my plane I think it was somewhat
ok but I'm sure he can he can take on h5
now and he really should I thought it
would be OK for me but it's not not not
not too clear but this is just winning
he needs to take take on h5 ok he also
was was down on the clock and maybe it's
not really used to to being down to one
minute or something okay this is just
just to clean one
yeah pretty tense game well thanks for
watching and I think I'll do I do to two
of these games today so this was the
first one and I said start the second
term immediately